hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again I did the
audio like three minutes ago but I
completely forgot to click the
commentary button on al gato so it feels
bad for me well yeah we're in the new
Halloween event we got the new
background got the new music killing it
in the background as well with the
jack-o'-lanterns and [ __ ] like that I
was originally gonna record this with
the face cam but going to the Xbox beta
app it was a hassle and a lagged like
almost every 30 seconds very
unappetizing to watch I was gonna do it
on PC but then I'd have to buy the
marching fire expansion so it was just
this whole headache so either way I was
just gonna do it like this hopefully
it's not too big of an issue but yeah
we're gonna be playing the Halloween
event got the mask on for jj-just
equipped it and I'm probably gonna be
playing with him and maybe soon glided
we'll see how long these matches go yeah
if you want to know all the stuff that's
in this event everything to be caught up
with you can click the I believe in the
top right above the players names on
screen right now you'll be taken to my
info video and you'll be shown all the
stuff that's in it the new mask outfits
the discount is stuff from last year
then you know the new weapon skins all
the type of stuff like that so
definitely if you want to be caught up
to date with that definitely cook that
video let's good started with the game
already to start we have a rep 37 Conca
37 no bushi a valkyrie to JJ's Tootsie
on DS not a bad mix up we got this
boo-ki skeletons with the top hats and
[ __ ] and cowboy hats really excited I
believe last season's was just I believe
last year's IR [ __ ] saying that last
season's was the skeletons but they had
bandanas and stuff so this is a little
bit different they not have hats instead
of bandanas which is pretty cool let's
change at least so I don't know I'm
pretty sure nothing has changed and I we
did play on the other map actually when
I stopped recording on the beta app I
had this all recorded on the other map
the one that changed everything so feels
bad we didn't get put on that map but
still it's completely ok
yeah bites you
one thing to also note is that endless
March is very similar to the reigning
Inferno event in the sense that a and B
are now not 100 points there are 200
points and B is now 0 points if you
capture it so there's really no point in
having B other than the fact that you
have a shit-ton dominions there so a and
C are the really the only things that
matter which is also why we're beating
this team 500 to 0 very interesting
score here against Mac much by C on D
gonna break him swap off for the other
one just gonna try to recover my stamina
here hopefully the Valkyrie will ya take
a few hits why recover beautiful
teamwork by me and her gonna do the
stamina move the out of stamina or art
garden move whatever you want to call it
I like this sprint attack I find JJ's
sprint attack to be one of the cooler
looking ones does actually a lot of
decent damage as well so all finally
they're on the board though with 200
points by the time we'll come back
how many times you're gonna spin my guy
goddamn man's just kept going
I'll take that bye-bye
damn it's a shame there goes my help
[ __ ] Christ to Haiti on D holy [ __ ] my
man's went off
bye-bye gotcha good night sir
it's the only time you ever see me perry
a xiaolin light Oh big bump
don't look away from me
got him with that big bait Oh My cod
with the [ __ ] and that's gonna be the
end of the game nice
yeah these games go fairly quickly I'm
not entirely sure how quick this match
was I'd probably say it was like eight
to nine minutes these do go quicker
remember because a and C is not 200
points and B is zero so there's really
no point to go to that middle objective
and fight over it it was about a
10-minute game not bad 18 and 5 I'll
probably test out gladiator I kind of
forgot to show off the mask but I also
apparently didn't equip it which is
weird so I'll make sure to have that on
for next game after game after game of
not getting this map we have finally got
River for River fort if you guys do not
know is the map you do want to be
playing for the audience March not
because dirt you know it's different in
terms of gameplay mechanics it just
looks a lot different and it's the only
map that has you know the stuff on it
has the green the fire the pumpkins all
that great stuff so this is honestly the
map do you want to be voting for if you
haven't played it the amount of games I
had to play just to get this map that to
even come up on the voting is stupid and
I'm gonna want to be free
got a double kill did the zone cuz I
need the double kill
I'm ten oh that's gonna hurt oh the big
spartan kick from t on d nice
damn you care bench again I kept that
was my bed that I gave that to him
[Music]
it's gonna keep toast stabbing him made
you know
JJ's got more stamina or more damage
that's not good he's waiting for that to
happen he's going off the map bye-bye oh
yeah just a quick locate basically
what's going on with this map is that
that you know all this stuff is now
green
the fire is green there's Cantonese
jack-o'-lanterns everywhere there's a
new show running at me with damage buff
that's not good we can get away from her
the smoke at that you know this little
mist here at the bottom is green crazy
stuff like I said the Dominions gonna be
doing mad damage which even went with a
debuff on now and this buzzer Kerr that
he'll get destroyed very quickly so
that's a very good play of him to not
stand in there see a little bit of a
confrontation that being a summit a
summit see of course us being
outnumbered in every single fight now
we're about to be even more are numbered
so I'm gonna probably help and hop in
real quick I'm dead now boys
just do the light attack get it over
with so that this deserter doesn't smack
me easy you know pop intervention of in
a 4v4 mode in a 1v1 situation I'm not an
[ __ ] hit him with the GAR break he's
about to throw me off that wasn't good
do a little faint
tutto stab easy stuff so this minions
gonna follow me don't know why he's
doing that
get away from me Oh step and that follow
up with a zone just going lost
completely owning right now until this
berserker starts doing faints and this
game is over but yeah you could want to
have a good run now you start trading
moves with him and backing up when
necessary
that should have been a heavy to the
other character to the deserter but it's
okay you know it well ignore it act like
it didn't happen
quick damage there I know I probably
could've done a heavy but I was you know
I'm just you get nervous quaking in my
boots right now and I'm dead how cuz I
knew she came from behind me no and the
soldiers did 13 to 14 damage
I believe if my calculations are correct
the pikemen do ten damage on breach so
these guys do even more
I believe the breach minions are
unaffected in terms of damage because
this is of course just the event mode if
you were to happen to do a regular
Dominion this would be normal stuff
except the minions in this mode the only
thing that really changes of course in
this event is that the minions do a lot
more damage it was normal Dominion
minions wouldn't change they would just
you know cosmetically they would change
damage values would stay the same same
thing with breach as well that's what I
was looking for I thought that I still
think that's a heavy attack in my head
but Berserker cross this faint clapping
me I found out the real only decent
losses to use the catapult on the
minions since obviously it's very
necessary you should be getting rid of
those minions just if you want to go
through the middle terms of capturing
the point there's a personal reason
what have had that parried if he didn't
miss so that screwed me up a bit
actually I've felt interesting
sometimes just trip on your own feet now
he has revenge and I'm definitely dead
yeah that's gonna be the end of me
that's gonna be the end of Paragon which
I believe was the greater so great so
it's a two on four hopefully T on DS in
a to be one ticks down the wall bringer
Kent se has a revenge now he's gonna
fight the Berserker completely whoops to
guard break collapsed abuser ker he now
it's to defeat this new show and get me
on the revived or this map is gonna be
over thick by now the realizing where
he's spawning so he needs to get this
stuff done but Nisha's light spam
standard council issue right there and
can say that's gonna be the game a
little background new is the background
as well didn't notice that from the last
game yeah I managed to win one managed
to lose one whatever one ten and seven
that's not bad at all I would say yeah I
guess it's gonna be the end of the video
hope you guys did enjoy like to be if he
did subscriber for new I cover the
informational site a foreigner that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes the leaks event news like
this all that good stuff like I said
check the videos on the top right if you
do want to see all the info and it also
be at the end of this video as well if
you don't want to do it right now I just
want to wait you'll be at the end of
this video if you want to get caught up
with all the info on for honor and stuff
like that especially with the new event
that just came out it'll be the most
recent video on screen is my two most
easy videos will be on screen if you
guys want to check that out but there
guys today I figured for us in the video
[Music]